c'est bon chez la profession vingtaine
d'années on est plus à cinq minutes près
latine
bonjour on faire un premier temps
à
chiche
oh le voilà toujours me mettre
dans la poche des douloureux pour le
coccyx de vous faut que je fasse rire
après les textos de ma fille qui vient
finir soir monfils qu'il a cessée verbe
rabeni mais aussi d'abus l'aria vie de
joueur à prendre et du vélo qu'il a fait
c'est pas terrible
mieux merci beaucoup albert et puis à
très bientôt merci ça veut dire michel
où j'ai le temps de mais on n'a pas le
temps bonjour on amène un deuxième
fauteuil variés à on va les gens qui ont
l'habitude de la télé du cinéma
ali bossi jeu qui n'était pas fini un
masque abstrait enfin quoi vous avez
rechange des photos c'est le dernier
réalisateur bart c'est bizarre cette
photo kp merci beaucoup à tous les deux
merci à vous merci j'ai récupéré la
descente de barr pas fait chaud on a un
peu de temps là où sandra l'envoie là
emilie messieurs dames
merci d'être là bonjour tenter de vous
recevoir c'est bien il faut papauté a
enfin j'arrive à faire résonner ça y est
ça aussi c'est grâce à vous alberta
demandé de lire le livre pas du tout et
je n'ai toujours pas lu la douceur quand
elle faisait preuve d'intelligence
vraiment presque sous cutanée m'aider
beaucoup pour construire le livre
d'après don ce personnage est l'héroïne
découvre ici
non mais le cheminement
[Musique]